all right so Sarah I know you're a huge
simp for Luan were you disappointed at
all with his inclusion in Insidious The
Red Door no not at all I had gone in
prepared to have no specs and Tucker no
Lee were now I was resigned to it but um
it was a really weird lovely surprise
especially as I started watching the
movie more it became apparent that they
weren't going to be a huge part of it
like they were in the previous films
yeah and it tied into chapter three as
well I mean that's how the Brenner
family found them it was through the
YouTube episodes yeah and that's one of
the things that I talked about in my
Insidious 3 video that uh that nobody
watched like the Insidious 3 they used
the same branding with the special
settings website and stuff as they do
for the viral marketing campaign from
Insidious 2. I thought it was weird that
they use that Insidious 3 but then they
use that again here so I found that kind
of funny oh I didn't notice that I'll
tell you what I did notice though on
letterboxed in the list of cast members
they didn't Leslie winnell and anger
Sampson for about the first week or
first few days and I don't know if that
was intentional to keep it as a surprise
but if you look on it now they are
listed that's interesting